compagnie
[Musique]
d'un côté les Manouches une communauté
qui voyage encore de l'autre des gitans
certains ont choisi de s'installer de ne
plus voyager comme cela qui occupe une
cité depuis plus de 10 ans près de
Montpellier ils sont généralement
rassemblés sous le nom de Tigan on les
appelle aussi confusément bohémien
romanichel ils sont près de 6 millions
dans le monde la plupart viennent du
nord de l'Inde ils sont arrivés en
France au 15ème siècle et depuis ils
vivent à côté de nous souvent rejetés
souvent persécutés dans les camps nazis
400 000 d'entre eux ont été exterminés
aujourd'hui encore il reste méconnu à
part
mon amour
moi je vais me promener est-ce qu'on
peut dire qu'ici commence la
scolarisation des enfants gitans oui il
commence ici ils arrivent à deux ans et
je les garde jusqu'à l'âge de 6 ans
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit après aller au CP
dis-moi au niveau de l'âge
des autres enfants de ce qu'on appelle
les Pailloux c'est-à-dire les Français
encore au caillou on peut dire que le
petit gitan ne reçoit pratiquement pas
d'éducation de la part de ses parents il
est dans la rue on lui demande rien on
lui fiche la paix il fait cet hiver
est-ce que la scolarisation ne comporte
pas certains risques pour eux
c'est-à-dire risque de perdre des
traditions la langue les coutumes au
niveau de la langue on peut rassurer
tout de suite même dans le jardin il
parle gitan entre eux par l'uniquement
le Gitan et à moi il s'adresse dans un
mélange dans un spontanément les enfants
parlent le gitan
chez les gitans la présence des anciens
et les relations entre frères et sœurs
permettent de vivre étroitement ensemble
dans le clan
[Musique]
de la vie
dis-moi ça va et les petites gitanes
c'est pareil que les Pailloux
qu'est-ce qu'elles ont différents
[Musique]
tu préfères être avec des gitans ou avec
des Pailloux aussi
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire quand tu vas
de grande Sarah
c'est vrai peut-être que dans ta famille
on va pas être content
ta maman va être d'accord qu'est-ce que
Jean-Pierre c'est rare que les filles
gitane
pourquoi tu dis ça
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de bien dans la vie
des gitanes et des gitans qu'est-ce que
vous aimez bien qu'est-ce qui est bien
qu'est-ce qui est bien qu'est-ce que
[Applaudissements]
vous a décidé vous à ne plus voyager à
rester sur place
de ne plus être un jour gitan et d'être
complètement intégré de venir
complètement Paillou non ça non
sur place tu penses que vous resterez
longtemps
grâce à quoi à la musique
[Musique]
mais quoi
[Applaudissements]
chez les Manouches le décor appelle
encore un peu la vie passée leur grand
voyage semble avoir commencé à l'an 1000
ici nous sommes dans un camp de nomade
comme tant d'autres dans le sud de la
France
bon anniversaire mon anniversaire
allez Diana
bon anniversaire que tu vis longtemps
mon fils que tu vois les enfants de tes
enfants amen
Joseph tu travailles pas aujourd'hui toi
aujourd'hui non
je travaille pas parce que j'ai pas de
travail ah bon qu'est-ce que tu fais toi
généralement
ah ben je fais tous les mecs parce que
tous les métiers quoi presque tous les
métiers
la famille José l'impression que chez
vous c'est
très important la famille chez vous
ma mère pour moi c'est tout qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire la maman c'est quoi la
maman qui est là
c'est leur vie nous on se sépare pas de
nos enfants il y a combien d'enfants ici
et ben moi j'en ai eu 7 et il y a assez
dedans que je suis seul ça m'arrive et
j'ai élevé mes 7 enfants toute seule
toujours
allez frotte madame est-ce que vous avez
élevé vos filles comme vos garçons oh ma
fille je l'ai plus surveillée davantage
que mes garçons on a l'impression qu'on
est très stricte
quand le garçon est dansé ou qui
sortaient je ne voulais pas qu'elle
sorte
que tu fais quand tu rentres
tu as des copines des petites amies
gadget
tu les vois où
en dehors de l'école tu les vois
tu les vois tu les vois à la maison
tu vas pas dans la maison pourquoi
tu aimerais y aller
et toi là tu vas tu vas chez des petites
camarades pourquoi tu vas pas pourquoi
tu n'y vas pas
tu as des copains toi non gitans
parce que son père est pas comme ça sur
gitan il aime pas les gitans vous allez
repartir la voyager parce qu'ici
maintenant on gagne pas notre vie on
fait des chaises on fait le ramonage en
fait des choses connues des choses en
paille alors
vous savez maintenant des chaises il y
en a plus beaucoup alors des fois on en
trouve une ou deux dans la journée des
fois on fait 2300 km partir reprendre la
route c'est à la fois par goût et par
nécessité ce matin une famille voisine a
quitté le campement
à Marseille aussi tu m'as dit
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire quand tu vas
être grand toi tu vas voyager ou tu vas
rester dans une maison et le voyage
dis-moi Gilles
qu'est-ce qui vous fait vous déplacer
sans arrêt comme ça là quand tu as
beaucoup voyagé quand tu étais jeune moi
j'ai beaucoup voyagé oui énormément
et ce qui nous fait déplacer c'est que
on a besoin de sentir en nous toujours
cette liberté dans ce sens que on se
sent énormément libre c'est pour ça
alors on a ça en créant nous on est né
comme ça sur le voyage et on a besoin de
vivre cette liberté ce qui est en nous
quoi
[Musique]